the money is tighter than he would like
Miller is proudly debt-free so now
here's where it turns here's where now
now remember remember he's cared for his
aging mother he's living in a basement
he's living in a basement of his
sister's house okay for 500 a month but
here's where the Wall Street Turtle here
we go put on a happy
face the money is tighter than he would
like Miller and by the way people say
like they're like are you making up
these articles these are you read them
you go and read them we'll post them
remember do you think I could make that
up where they're like you don't need a
bathroom MH what is this 1998 dining
room kitchen no the new houses are a
single hallway with little cages on
either side